tiling patterns show up everywhere in
nature in the structure of a honeycomb
the skin of a giraffe or in the Petals
of a flower
now researchers have developed a new way
of making patterns with cells locking
them together like Legos to produce
beautiful tiling Arrangements
diversity of Arizona in Tucson has
engineered E coli bacteria with
synthetic adhesions proteins that sit on
the surfaces of cells and allow them to
interact with one another adhesives work
like keys that fit into specific locks
as bacteria multiply they form colonies
that expand or swarm normally when two
colonies meet they create one giant
colony
but when the bacteria with adhesives
swarm together the two colonies form an
edge where the keys and locks meet and
that opens up some opportunities to get
creative
here the researchers engineered colonies
formed by bacteria with locks to Glow
green and those with keys to glow red
they turn yellow where the locks and
keys come together
larger faster growing colonies with a
key could grow around smaller colonies
with the corresponding lock
what's more by engineering cells to
produce one of two different keys and
two different locks they could start to
create geometric patterns
using mathematical principles the
scientists could model where to pipette
bacteria with different kinds of
adhesions onto a grid Matrix this allows
them to create a range of complex
patterns
the bacteria could also be used to make
linear designs including the homage to
the University of Arizona
the researchers say that the adhesive
technology could be used to design
biomaterials or new tests for diseases
they might even shed light on how life
grew in complexity as single-celled
organisms evolved into multicellular
creatures
[Music]